chile vive este viernes su primera
jornada sin toque de queda ni estado de
excepción la forma administrativa que
permite que este toque de queda asociado
a una alerta sanitaria sea posible el
país había estado en toque de queda
desde en marzo de 2020 es decir 18 meses
en el que los chilenos no podían salir
en la calle a determinadas horas de la
noche más de 500 días en los que se
restringió de forma importante está
libertad los chilenos celebraban la
noche acudiendo a restaurantes en todos
los lugares del país el hecho de poder
acudir hasta más tarde salir a la calle
reunirse con personas todo esto se ha
producido debido a que las cifras de
contagios han sido bastante bajas en las
últimas semanas por ejemplo este viernes
se registraron 846 casos positivos
confirmados 8 fallecidos y una
positividad a nivel nacional y un nuevo
22% también se ha podido producir esta
mayor apertura que significa el cierre y
el fin del estado de excepción por el
avance de la vacunación de 15,2 millones
de personas que constituyen la población
objetivo frente a los 19 millones de
chilenos ya se han vacunado un 91 una
dosis y 188 ha recibido las dos dosis o
ha completado su sistema de inoculación
seguido un momento por tanto de mayor
calma y libertad en chile en lo referido
a la pandemia